il fallait du sang froid et de la
dextérité ce week-end pour réaliser des
performances au concours régional jeunes
de guyancourt une véritable tradition
pour le club local qui a été sélectionné
par la ligue ile de france pour la
troisième année consécutive au rendez
vous regroupez encore cette année les
meilleurs jeunes archers d'île de france
en fait il ya un classement qui est fait
sur les trois meilleures performances de
toute la saison et à l'issue de ce
classement on extrait les x meilleurs
par catégorie
donc c'est les catégories les plus
représentées on va prendre plus de monde
et puis les catégories où il ya un peu
moins de participants
eh ben on va prendre juste quelques
quelques participants sur les deux jours
l'événement réunissant 92 jeunes archers
des catégories benjamins et minimes
pendant la compétition les sportifs ont
pu décocher deux séries de dix volées de
trois flèches pour montrer leur
précision 24 cibles ont été installés
dans la salle
c'est bien de s'affronter au meilleur de
l'île de france est donc aussi juste
pour permettre une compétition
l'expérience des duels et juste pour
m'amuser aussi en même temps pour voir
mon niveau par rapport aux autres
et puisque
il ya mon entraîneur aussi qui m'a dit
que c'était pas mal de coups bas j'y
suis allé j'ai il peut y avoir du bon
niveau mais oui oui c'est une bonne
compétition à faire les vainqueurs du
jour ont pris une sérieuse option en vue
des qualifications pour les championnats
de france jeunes 2017
la compétition sera organisée les 17 18
et 19 février à nîmes